covid-19 has changed the lives of many
around the world but the stress that
came with it is still lingering on for
some more than two years later Victoria
Saha explains how it could be affecting
the sleep
[Music]
pandemic stressors are still affecting
the lives of many people trying their
best to address back into normalcy I'm
averaging three hours of sleep a night
for the last two months and Courtney
Olson says that's because of the stress
the pandemic brought I'm in the apparel
business and supply chain issues you
know really Logistics everything was so
slowed down that it just caused an
immense amount of stress and of course
that's now carried over pre-pandemic she
was averaging six hours of sleep a night
and now no matter what she tries now
it's hard for her to get a good night's
rest the tiredness has been the most
unnerving because we're all so mentally
wound up you know and on high alert for
a literal two-year period according to
the Sleep Foundation A study says around
40 percent of people have had issues
sleeping during the pandemic Las Vegas
therapist Denisha Mingo says among other
issues she's seen an increase of
patients coming in regarding sleep for
us on the mental health side we have not
seen a decline in that phone ringing
Mingo says with schedules being thrown
off for two years and the weight of
feeling anxious has resulted in an
increase of people using sleep aids she
also says the stressors from the
pandemic are allowing people to make
their mental health a priority and with
the acceptance of it's okay if I'm not
okay it's okay to get mental health
support and I don't have to be in crisis
to give mental health support Victoria
Saha 8 News Now